[Applause]
the broken belongings of those who died
in a desperate attempt to escape
afghanistan
it was here by this sewage canal that a
suicide bomber destroyed their dreams
two british men and the teenage child of
a third uk national now confirmed as
being among the dozens who were killed
they've been trying to get onto
evacuation flights before all british
and u.s forces leave our thoughts today
are very much with
their families and their and their loved
ones and
i think what
their loss really underlines is the the
urgency of getting on and
concluding operation pity in the way
that we in the way that we are and also
it underlines the the bravery of our
armed services
but they went into afghanistan to rid it
of terrorists and help its people
instead 20 years on they're leaving
behind chaos
this foreign office crisis centre
helping with the retreat so unable to
help everyone
there will
uh sadly be people who
haven't got through people who who might
qualify and what i would say to
to them is that we will shift heaven and
earth to help them get out we will do
whatever we can
in in the second phase among the people
left behind will be dozens if not
hundreds of former interpreters for
british forces viewed as traitors by the
taliban
one former interpreter with british
forces has spent the past five days
outside the airport trying to get onto
one of these flights he's now in hiding
with his family including his
three-month-old baby still waiting and
hoping for a call forwards
he's too scared to speak in english with
me on the phone in case the taliban
overhear him so we've been messaging
instead i asked him how he's feeling and
he said fearful and lost like a prisoner
waiting for his assassination
i also asked what his message was to the
uk government and he said it's just to
stand on your words as you are known as
great britain you should be great not
silly british troops and diplomats past
and present feel a growing sense of fury
i'm angry all of my peers all of my
colleagues i speak to miami are angry
this is
just i'm speechless
yeah friends of mine are going to die
friends of mine what i assaulted with in
2010 are left behind
lives will be lost and their blood sits
firmly on pretty patel ben wallace's
hands
as the evacuation effort enters its
final hours the home secretary and
defense secretary are doing what they
can to get as many out as possible all
amidst the very real threat of another
terrorist attack
but british forces have started to
withdraw as well
this plane the latest to arrive back in
the uk courage and despair at the close
of this mission
debra haynes sky news